should I start a business on eBay I got
a question from one of my youtube
readers love you guys John who wrote in
to to tell me about this business
opportunity he's working on he's trying
to drop a plan for an eBay business he's
been watching videos by this eBay coach
his eBay guru who's telling him you got
to start a business on eBay so way to
make a lot of money but he doesn't give
the specifics on how to do it and so
John's trying to reverse engineering
figure it out for himself and wanted my
advice and what to do
John this sounds to me like a
get-rich-quick kind of scheme and I hate
these things let's back up for a second
okay before we even get into eBay the
reason why you want to start a business
is because you want to have a positive
change in the world you're passionate
about something you see a problem that
exists and you want to solve it and your
business is a way to do it it's not
about just trying to make a lot of money
it's not about just trying to buy a
lifestyle that earns you money so you
can sit on the beach somewhere that gets
boring really quickly make your business
important stand for something be a
change be a force for good why are you
doing this when you figure that out then
everything else will fall in place
and maybe you end up with an eBay
business or maybe it's something totally
different this reminds me a lot of a lot
of the network marketing companies I
know what marketing can work and there's
some great people at it and some of them
sell great products but a lot of people
write in to me and they say how do I
have success with my network marketing
business and the problem right from the
outset is they're starting the business
because they're just trying to make a
lot of money they have no passion no
interest no knowledge about the product
or industry they're getting into that's
it you're doomed for failure from the
start you have to know and have
expertise and love what you're selling
that's that's successful business right
there so don't look at eBay as your
vehicle to make tons of
start higher up and maybe EB becomes
part of your your process but maybe it's
not at all if you're struggling right
now with I want to start an eBay
business and I don't know what the
saddle I just want to find whatever it's
cheap and I can sell online make a lot
of money you're gonna fail it's not
gonna work that's not the way to build a
great business that's a get-rich-quick
I'm not interested in what I'm selling
I'm just trying to make a lot of money
the guys who just trying to make a lot
of money never make money you look at
any successful entrepreneur look at the
biggest names that you can think of in
entrepreneurship if you're looking at
Oprah Winfrey Donald Trump
Bill Gates any of these guys they didn't
start their business trying to make tons
of money that becomes part of it you
have to make money and if you're
providing a really valuable product or
service you will make a lot of money but
it's not the reason to get into business
so that's what I'm struggling with right
now with John's question and if that's
you if you're starting this business
just trying to make money cut out early
because you're gonna lose money buying
product signing up for fees set up for
accounts waste your time waste your
money waste your energy it's not gonna
work use that energy and those resources
more effectively and stand for something
important do something important with
your company if you figure that part out
you're on your way to greatness and a
lot of money to believe so those are you
watching like the video give it a thumbs
up below let me know what you think
leave a comment you have a question for
me leave it in the comment section below
I maca video response and subscribe to
the channel if you want to see more
videos like this thank you so much and
I'll see you soon